how do you know that's what
happened my man i didn't get to that
point yet i didn't get today
[Laughter]
heroin never did heroin i feel like if
you're gonna do one that's like how
steve said like that was a win
ooh never did black talk never touched
black talk
like balloons dropped you know yeah but
matt
yeah i've smoked matt yeah oh you smoked
matt oh yeah bob did too bob [ __ ]
near arizona state at some random
apartment i was just hanging out in some
guy's living room
it was one of those drug places where i
would just end up being
sure and he just walked in and he was
like you only spoke to matt
and you're like yeah okay and then was
were you what kind of high is meth well
i just remember going back to my dorm
room and
feeling my heart beat like it was like
it was a hummingbird yeah it was like
and then i was i remember just like
looking out the window and the sun was
coming out and i'm like oh no i have
was it a fun high or no no no i don't
think you would like it
no the only thing i'm jealous of when i
see meth addicts how skinny they are
that's the only temptation not only that
they're uh you know meth mouth is a real
thing
oh yeah yeah yeah because if you're a
rich
head couldn't you get veneers and just
keep smoking that crack i don't know
i don't know you just spit behind an
idea first of all
you making it out like somebody doing
meth that's making good life choices
that's so like they're like you're
struggling how can i properly do meth
yeah look at these pictures the before
and after at that
i mean the one on the right that's a
different woman
oh my goodness holy [ __ ] see i never got
to that point why why why do they have
scabs on their face
yeah damn she was a diamond before they
pick on their face and stuff
yeah yeah i'd have to have a picture of
her on her back if she looked like this
yeah you know what i mean like what she
used to
oh my gosh see how healthy the guy left
oh my god
i mean how many pounds do you think he
lost right there i mean ooh he's ready
for the fight like that's how you that's
what i'm saying yeah
like tj dillashaw 10 125. if i went to
ufc events
this guy god dawg that looks like a ufc
fan on the right that's me on the left
that's tj on the right yeah
that was it you didn't hear that veil
dig by uh steve i know what he's saying
he's like
you know ufc fans they're methods
not all of them i'm sure some just a
good one yeah some of them maybe
like no you gotta fight here rip his hat
off you're like all right dude
what is this now that was the goalie
from uh
good now yeah mighty ducks yeah he he he
fell on some hard times but he got back
together yeah
yeah literally turns you into a zombie
on the right at this point
oh good for him yeah so he got sober
all i'm saying is look at the weight
loss though yeah that's 100 pounds off
top huh
forget about all this working it was
crazy he went from like this little kid
to that he became his grandfather
and then and then he like then he turned
then he turned back into like
you know what i mean like he literally
became his own grandfather yeah he did
and then chocolate bar look how good his
teeth look on the his teeth look healthy
yeah those are yeah you can see like
jared leto playing his own grandpa yeah
[Music]
acid yeah acid yeah you're just a wild
boy oh yeah
but that's when i stopped because when i
saw dead people in my dorm room bathroom
i'm like okay
that was rock bottom yeah well that was
one of them i'm like i don't want to see
a different dimension where was your
because i watched a lot of intervention
what was your rock bottom
did did your family i did it on my own
it wasn't that gnarly it was like i woke
up one morning in
like the shittier apartment i lived in
the one that you didn't go to okay
the shoe box the shittier apartment
i can't even imagine
wait a minute you had a [ __ ] in your
apartment
and you you told me i like nice yeah i
like it yeah you're okay
but i know you do but it was bad yeah it
was a shoe box so it was literally
shaped like
it was like i i couldn't even fit you
know like the different size beds like
king and then you have full or queen
mine was like
what are they what's the kid kid's best
sleeping bag twin
so i could only fit a twin and i didn't
even have like a frame it was just on
the ground
that was rock bottom because you're yeah
well i was i had diarrhea and i was
throwing them
one morning and i'm like you know i
don't want to do this anymore good for
you man yeah and that was how long ago
over 12 years ago you never got into no
alcohol you know no no alcohol no drugs
you're
you're sober yeah yeah you don't drink
either huh at all i drink
what are you drinking whiskey oh no just
whiskey but you're not an alcoholic not
far from it so you do it once in
a month or maybe if i'm on the road i'll
have a drink before a show but that's
but you know you look at the studies man
any amount of alcohol is poison oh for
sure like there's no amount of alcohol
that's good for you
yeah i don't even mess with no duels you
know there's that oh duels that tastes
like beer
which is ridiculous but why would i do
that yeah it wouldn't be like i mean why
because it wasn't about like is it as if
you were drinking beer for the taste
i do like the taste though yeah yeah
like a cold beer on a summer day oh
man you redneck
when i was in high school i i was at a
party and just peer pressure i was like
yeah i'm gonna drink a beer
i had like two sips of that [ __ ] and i
was like no thank you
you've never been that was it for
nothing yeah no the only time i've ever
like decided to like drink was like
way later in life when i went on
vacation with a buddy just because i
said okay i'll do
it one time just to see what it's about
you know and i had like uh
some champagne on the plane and i was
like ugh okay yeah and then i was on the
beach i had a banana colada
and my first thought was they just
ruined this good ass shake
with this nasty yeah that makes sense
and then and then after that the last
thing i did
i was done after this you know i said to
myself again i'm talking about i'm in my
40s at this point
was like um they had like at the at the
hotel bar
uh it was like drink of the day and i
was like all right let me try to drink
it today
yeah about that much and i was like
you're set no thank you
just the way it made me feel and all
this stuff i was like ugh no no adderall
no no
riddling no that at all you don't mess
with that raw
no that's isn't that like a cold beer on
a summer day
no that that is not that is not i
understand certain people need it that's
like some meth and van eyes
yeah this is what you mean i mean no i
understand people need
need to function yeah they get hooked on
it my thing was uh bloody
beers what's that that's like uh my dad
used to drink it it's a v8
or clam or tomato juice mixed with uh
beer i thought you were saying tomato
juice i thought it was gonna say like
virgin period yeah
you just seemed like there was like some
kind of witchy thing going on
in it that's it it's about the most
sexual it gets you stick a stick in it
yeah
stevie speaking of getting rid of your
dark ways you're thinking about uh
bringing that
that black butt in there i thought of it
i read a comment or something and i
thought it'd be a good ritual or uh
we could do a ceremony how should we
send it off though because originally i
was like oh it's set on fire
shoe box or something and i'll bring it
here we'll set it on the
can i bring it into the studio sure and
you guys won't get offended
no theo's not here and then we'll put
some flowers in
the box you need a white butt of theo
was here
all right so i think it would be a good
uh maybe
a good thing to do good way to see it go
out i could
grow past it yeah i want to set it on
fire i'm just worried about all the
oil i'll burn the whole building down no
we're not going to do that we could do
one of those chinese lanterns
and send it off in the uh oh in the
water
oh you know what we could do like game
of thrones we'll put in the water and as
it goes i'll take an
arrow and go like are you you're right
expert marksman you're you're legal
that'd be great content that'd be dope
we could do a vlog
yeah i might take a couple arrows but
yeah i like that uh
next week we're gonna be in the new
thick boy king in the sting studio so
i'll bring it
no this is real this is growth oh yeah
i'm with it whatever helps you move on
from this
place i won't be able to use it again i
bet that thing [ __ ]
justice
oh you didn't get enough you didn't get
enough last week or when you come out of
the shower you're just like stop
oh i'm holding it no no you got your
towel then you see it and you're just
doing it it's in my closet dude
you don't talk [ __ ] dude like who is
this closet it's in my closet
which is also his den
all right let's do a king interview
let's move past
this dude i like that dude i like the
idea i love your boys we'll do that
you know i love you yeah
what a king in this nathan coming live
from your mama's house
on her [ __ ] couch aggressive uh yeah
i've got a king interesting
for you transgender olympians do we
believe they exist can they participate
in support
let me know peace what is it a ghost
they're like you know what i mean what
is it
are they real flatterers uh
here's the thing that like the one
transgender athlete in the olympics
demon place
yeah it was a male to female and she
didn't even place
yeah but but now the ufc i'm not the
olympics came out said
come on dude i mean that come on yeah
that and also how you know what
how you making a place bro but i'm
saying okay just at first glance
if i said what what is this you would be
like oh that's somebody's dad yeah this
is a male weight lifting
all right okay let's be can i can we be
sensitive for a second though it's like
because what happens with this subject
is
people's emotions and feelings get
involved and it's like a layered issue
it's not just one thing it's like yes
are we supportive of the transgender
community yes i am all right yeah me too
yeah all right we're supportive
i have my own experience personal
experience yeah oh we have to get to
that
so the other part is this like the other
part is this is i don't know why we
can't just use common sense about this
if brendan here decided that he figure
figured out that
he wanted to be brenda okay uh i don't
know if hormones and all the treatment
are going to take away your muscle mass
and your structure
and then who you are and what what that
is there you know you might
are trying to live your truth and you're
like okay i'm brendan now and i've done
this thing
but like you're still brendan brendan
shaw the bone density
density and all this stuff and so for
those kind of people to be competing
with people who
don't have that same advantage i don't
know why this is such a big deal
people think that we're you're
anti-trans when you talk like this no
it's just
what we just haven't caught up to what's
happening in the world
so the olympic committee just needs to
be like okay so now we need to have a
new category that's what i say
you know just doing a new category you
should not be allowed to compete
right just create a a category for them
and compete against other
you know what's crazy in in ufc fighting
in ufc fighting uh there's a weight
class for steve
and there's a weight class for you yeah
they don't let you
fight this fight class [ __ ] reason
there's a reason
okay so i don't i don't understand why
well i don't understand why
you can't extrapolate that and think
about it in the same way
when it comes to a person that has this
strength and muscle mass and bone
density and all that advantage playing
against somebody who does it
in boxing we did the same thing in all
male sports
we know you can't fight against somebody
in 120 rounds that's not fair
because it's not fair yeah yeah it's
weird
that's what you have to say right up
front we are very supportive of the
trans
you know community and live your truth
we want that but don't sit here and act
like you don't know what the [ __ ] we're
talking about like i was watching to see
on the experiences someone who was
transgender
it was born of uh was born a boy
transition to female
and then she's like undefeated in
wrestling high school like obviously
beats the [ __ ] out of these girls
oh yeah but then she was like all right
because she kept getting booed like
she'd win the crowd would boo yeah she
felt bad so she was like all right let
me compete against the boys
and the state went letter she was like
all right i want to wrestle
so i guess i'll just keep beating up
these girls yeah
see that's the thing is the the society
hasn't caught up to this yet yep
you know what i mean so we have to like
you know it's like you know it's like
now you go you know it's starting to
catch up and start
especially in the sort of like woke
liberal more place urban
community type place cities you know you
go to a place now and it's like
you know all gender bathrooms now yep
you know that's them catching up to like
they go okay
we can't just have male female because
people are going to come over and go
which one can i go to or which one
something happened in the korean spa did
you oh yeah yeah that was the big deal
the remember the wii spice
you know i used to go there yeah see
that one makes sense like
it was it was a male who transitioned a
female and that the wii spot
but she was in the female 1
and then the lady's there with her
daughter and she's like bro this
this guy's in the [ __ ] spot with this
big dick in my daughter's face like
and he was like well i'm i'm a woman
she's like we'll know you're going to
identify as you have your big dick in
front of my kid's face yeah so then they
protest
it got nasty what i mean do you hear
michael chase joke
he said he said uh he didn't understand
why i can't call transgender [ __ ] for
the longest
they said one of his uh gay friends was
like uh
is it okay if i call you blackie he was
like oh that makes sense
sometimes that's all you need let's take
a little break from chat with the boys
sharing some pretty intimate stories
hello
fresh you get fresh pre-measured
ingredients mouth-watering
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
crib skip the trips to the grocery store
and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy
fun and affordable man and that's why
it's america's number one
meal kit all right hello fresh cuts out
stressful meal planning grocery store
trips
with less prep time less effort and
minimal
clean up so you can enjoy cooking and
get dinner on the table in just about 30
minutes
you got 30 minutes to make great food
yeah you do
this summer hellofresh has everything
you need to get grilling grilling
bundles
burger packs surf and turf for your
mouth and less shopping and more
sizzle for the grizzle all right i love
uh grilling with hello fresh i do all
the burgers for the fam
it's my favorite thing they got go to
hellofresh.com 14
king and use the code 14 king for up to
14 free
meals plus free shipping go to
hellofresh.com
14 king use the code 14 king for up to
14 free meals plus free shipping
america's number one meal kit hello
fresh
today's king the sting with eric griffin
and stevie wiebe is brought to you by
athletic greens
the most comprehensive daily nutritional
beverage that's ever touched my thick
lips
oh it's delicious one tasty scoop of
athletic greens
contains 75 vitamins minerals whole
foods source ingredients
including a multivitamin multi-mineral
probiotic green superfood blend
and so much more that all work together
to fill in those gaps you're missing in
your diet your diet's weak son
so athletic greens helps you out all
right and right now athletic greens is
doubling down on supporting your immune
system during the winter months even
though it's the summer winter is coming
like game of thrones
they're offering you guys a free
one-year supply of vitamin d
get that d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase
if you visit the link today you
basically never have to buy vitamin d
ever again simply visit
athleticgreens.com kats
and join the health experts athletes
podcasters
comedians everybody go-getters around
the world making a daily commitment to
their health every day
visit athleticgreens.com kats
get your free year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs today
all right let's get it but back to you
and your let's go next
time all we want to know is
when did you find out was it after you
already had i just want to defend myself
it could have been a woman too sure what
happened man it could have been one
because
before you tell yourself brian cowan was
in thailand
and he found out pretty late and then
went down there
he was making out while he was cuddling
for else
he was making out with his transgender
uh woman he didn't know making out me
you know
and said and then said he would like
reach down and just grabbed a
thick rug nuts and he said he said he
felt so bad for he was like i just kept
making out
like no i i didn't want her to do that
i tried to do that but they kept
blocking my hand oh
because i go hey can i can i just see it
and you know
did you say it like that yeah he was
being so tender
check it out the person responded like
no
no and i'm just like oh okay so i was in
the philippines
doing uh music video shoots out there
all right and uh
you know where our hotel was situated
there was like that kind of activity
and i knew i had the next day off and
then out there they uh they
it was kind of like these business uh
there's these crews like
these massage teams had different like
one crew of girls would have like
you know pink uh polo shirts another
crew will have like
teams yeah they would have like cruise
sounds fantastic and they did hang out
outside the hotels and so like i i
didn't think twice like
you know because i i had a bunch of
these cards in my house so do you pick
one in the whole crew or the whole crew
coming yeah so i knew i had the next day
off and i'm like and then it was a
pretty
what i thought was a pretty female
filipino woman
and i go oh okay and then i took a
shower and i'm like oh i have the next
day off
um i'll just get a massage so she came
up to your room yeah and what happened
well i noticed that the lighting um
exposed a little bit of a like makeup
deterioration and i
and then uh adam's apple yeah adam's
apple
and no the voice hi i'm
clary yeah the voice is a little bit but
did she come in like all cute like oh my
god this place is so cute
like god damn it yeah voice was a little
deeper than i thought really
wait hold on though hold on we have to
go we have to back up
no no no no no no no no no when she
walks when she walked in
when she walked in you already saw the
adam's app on the deterioration as you
said
and at that point that didn't stop you
from going forward so go on from there
so you saw the adam's apple in the
makeup and you were like i'm here
you're kind of like i hate the way
you're working first off i hate
you know i was like i'll get a massage
but what ended up happening was
i just said you know what this person's
here i could use a massage you know
because you're doing like four
music videos yeah yeah you're like
16-hour shoot dates or whatever you're
bundled up and so what ended up
happening was
what was what was that all about yeah
yeah
i'm enjoying you got knots in your bag
i like how gently you're getting to how
you got sucked off by a dude
how do you know that's what happened my
man i didn't get to that one yet
i didn't get into that
hold up
time's there for the memes he's like
i don't like how you're assuming
bullseye
two minutes later you're right so what
happened dude so
are we doing family feud again survey
says
i'm just doing this okay butt naked hold
up hold up
he or she had some great oils by the way
the massage was great
regardless doing this [ __ ] up in the
air
very comfortable it was a great massage
it was a great massage and so i
i just noticed i was just doing this
sure you're relaxed yeah i'm relaxed i'm
having a good a very good
like deep tissue massage on my shoulder
blades and you're in the philippines
nobody's around that one yeah um and
then i just said
something in my brain kind of like
flipped sure
so i'm doing this and i just go suck me
off
i just go hey can you just finish me off
like a hello kitty cartoon you know what
i mean
just finished so i think i think a man
how could he or she say no to that dude
so then what
we can finish off was it it was a damn
good blow job
this was pretty good pretty good it was
a pretty good one there we go
there we go what did it set you back 14
bucks some [ __ ] like that
i don't know if that it was that cheap
but it happened
and uh at least it's probably
i mean good for you man yeah but it was
a life experience yeah yeah
but i like how about he owned that
situation i love that he just owned that
situation
because steve you already knew when the
person walked in you were all like you
know
okay you know exactly no no no it was a
progressive thing
it was a progressively you started
putting the clues together like first
48.
i was trying to justify right right
maybe she got sore throat
she got stung by a bee he was like
implanted allergies man
you know what she has some bad fish yeah
in the throat shellfish yeah
it's hot outside there's probably a man
or a woman
in the pants can we at least fairly say
it could have been a woman too right
no but that but that's fine my favorite
part is you turn on going
and he probably didn't even want to do
it he was like i guess i gotta you know
i was like oh man i'm gonna be like
those are the rules yeah so uh
if you asked but like in my defense like
a transgender genie this
was a very it look if you were to see
this person you'd say oh that's a pretty
woman
yeah yeah yeah that's a very i've heard
like in the philippines like thailand
like the lady boys
yeah she was very here she was
at least that's what people don't like
how we look at each other
so yeah we're trying to like make uh
yeah good for you man that's the story
so you know
it's not that i'm proud of you yeah
thank you what else you got nick
uh this guy has one that's semi-related
to the previous discussion brandon
stevie and eric got a king interesting
for you guys dating a girl with a boy's
name her name is bobby with an i
her dad's name is bobby with the y uh
she said she got made fun of as younger
but she embraced it now she likes it
my cousin jeremy shadow germ makes fun
of her calls her bob or robert
whatever but uh yeah well you're gonna
sing it let me know what you guys think
she's a diamond dime
i love it dog nothing's better than a
girl with a guy's name it's dope to me
that's ryan's another one that's a girl
yeah you're right well he could go for
brooklyn oh she's super diamond yeah her
name could be [ __ ] day for all i know
yeah dude i think it'd be weird if steve
uh dated a bobby
yeah because my brother's name is bobby
yeah that is
weird cause you don't want to be like
stuck my dick bobby
hey hey bobby could you finish me up
yeah you couldn't do that that would be
that would be too much yeah
stevie those puppy dog guys yeah hey i
hate to be too much trouble but
could you finish me off
okay that was an easy king by the way
this girl's a smoke show
it's another olympic related one hey
brandon hey eric hey stevie
this is remdog coming at you from
vermont i got a king in her sting it for
you
so simone biles coming back to the same
olympics she dropped out of
i once knew this drunk girl in college
who said she had the twisties
she tried to do a front flip over a beer
pong table
so we didn't hang out with her that much
after
needless to say all right king or
stinging
gang gang a lot of mellow dudes today
huh
he's in vermont he's like
that's a kind of a complicated one this
she was the uh gymnast right
yeah it came out that she's she's been
on medication yeah she was off her meds
right
it's tough because that that medication
is a form of
performance-enhancing drug
tokyo runs a tight ship every other
olympic committee lets her take it
i guess venus and serena were also on it
but it's uh
what it does it's prolonged energy and
focus
it's kind of like battles just because
she's been on for a while doesn't make
it
any less performance is that why she
could do she no i think she's talented
no matter what
the best time yeah but what's tough is
you know let's say she
did have a real problem and she needed
this medication
and she's been on it performing on it
for her entire career and then she gets
to tokyo
like nope can't do it and she's been on
it forever and then i get off it i guess
one of the symptoms is that what they
call the flippies or whatever
where you have birthdays yeah so you
can't do [ __ ]
well you know a lot of people are like
you know even we talked about this last
time and i saw a lot of
negative comments like you guys are
making fun of her and she's been this
and that and then you know
whatever happened with the doctor and
all these people all these poor
gymnasts had to deal with these like
creeps you know and all that stuff but
the thing here is that you know you know
you know she i feel bad for what she's
had to deal with
even with this even if having to get off
that and all that but like you have
responsibilities
like if i go to a show and i get to the
town
and like for whatever reason i can't do
the show
good reason or not i have to cancel the
show
yeah yeah and like there's refunds and
there's like maybe there's
responsibilities and it's like uh you
know
another thing you know so it's like this
documentary on peacock called golden it
explains all this i didn't know it but
that that olympic team they can only
bring
four team members and then an additional
two
individually so when she was out she
basically eliminated a whole team member
from the whole competition
so that puts a lot of pressure that girl
there
first mong athlete from minnesota they
have a mother
what's wrong mung is like have you seen
uh what's that that that grand torino
gran torino like that from uh
a lot of them are minnesota they're
they're asian right they what kind of
asian
like kind of more southeast looking um
like that time like moana uh no like
more louse looking yeah but she's
and they're bigger right the medalist
from the hmong community friendship
she's she's a superstar now like simone
miles dipping out and then she took over
and she won all these golds and [ __ ] and
she's a pretty girl
yeah she's like all right girl enjoy
this enjoy them flippies and then did
her [ __ ] yeah that was what i'm saying
again it's just another layered issue of
like yes we could feel bad for her that
whatever is going on with her personally
what she had to deal with
but you know you're also talking about
they work for this for four years since
they're kids dude
the teammates like he's talking about
the whole team you know the team is like
man i'm sorry to say she let her um
there's all them you're talking the
girls still got
silver like this they don't want silver
girl they're expecting gold
they want gold so yeah it's toxic it's
also we're weaponizing mental health now
like i know it is an issue but now all
anybody has to say is oh mental health
issues and we're like oh
but check this out though i saw this
because i love this show speak for
yourself it
comes on fox with marcellus wiley and
emmanuel acho shout out to those guys
but like what they are professional
athletes you know they and he and he
made a great point of that
it was fantastic he made a great point
of like saying
professional athletes can't diagnose
themselves
you know they can't go i think i have
whatever so i can't
that's not going to play no they gotta
go to the doctor and the doctor has to
say well actually whatever it is but it
but you know
but now professional athletes are just
automatically saying like
hey you know i this is why i can't do
this and they can't touch it the doc the
team can't like you know what i mean
i don't know man i mean look we should
be more aware
leery of mental health i mean we should
be more like hey let's let's
start taking care of this because it's
such a stigma on it and you know
especially for guys guys are all yeah i
agree and i think we're making
advancement
my only thing is like let's say you were
the owner of the birkeland nets right
and you paid kyrie irving
300 million dollars to play for your
basketball team yeah we have a contract
bro you're gonna play
so when he misses whatever three weeks
and goes mental health i need a break
it's like
okay then give us our money back yeah
well you know what they need to make
this
part of that service is the same way
they have doctors well they now need to
have like part of the contract should be
like
well you have a mental health doctor too
that has to you have to talk to when you
have to like you know
that's all i'm saying is we have to just
update what we're doing or maybe give
them like
certain date like give them like
whatever like sick days at work
like you have eight sick days so if you
you need a mental
break although you're a professional
athlete if you need a mental break
take your eight sick days away but in
this scenario don't you think like
because it's the olympics right
you're taking away a full team member
off the road it's a problem for sure
don't you think they should change the
rules if something like that happens in
the future like where someone could sub
in and be the fourth
substitute like people would take
advantage where the person was that was
like
they didn't make their like you know how
they have like there's tons of them yeah
but here's the thing though if you're
that person let's say it's like five
people and you're number six and you
didn't make it
you would just definitely jump but i
know but but you always are gonna know
you didn't really make
i know but still there's still a part of
you that's like i didn't really earn
this
you know what i mean the people are
going like super bad on her like that
upsets like come on bro she's going
through a lot and there's a [ __ ]
i mean that kind of pressure i know but
it may be one thing if this was her
first olympics and you're like oh she
can't handle the pressure
she's the most decorated of all time
i think she understands the pressure so
i think what we're just saying is like
yeah so this is the thing that happens
there it's not like
nba where you have 82 games and like in
the middle of your like
this is every four years you knew the
job was dangerous going into it like you
know it's like leading
up to it it's like you know curveballs
there's that them
tokyo being like you can't have
medication yeah so that's the thing i
didn't even know about that one yeah
that does make a big difference
they should have notified her so she
could prep for that like
and that was ritalin specifically
adderall you still can get approved even
in japan but
not ritalin which is just another common
and you would consider that
perfect performance enhancement she was
freaking out the whole time
yeah you have anxiety and everything if
you've been on it your entire career
goes away well career obviously it's
been on her entire life it feels like
you know you just
you take that away yeah hey man mental
health is a thing now
yep it's a real thing people are finally
addressing it guys gals all around the
world
maybe there's some interfering with your
happiness preventing you from achieving
your maximum potential we got you
covered man
better help is here to assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional
therapist start communicating under 48
hours listen not a crisis line not
self-help we're talking about
professional
counseling professionals not your
friends around the water
cooler not your friends that you're
taxing about your problems
we talk about professional help
worldwide all right log into your
account anytime send a message your
counselor
and you will get a response back all
right we got you covered man
better help is more affordable than
traditional offline counseling
and financial aid is available if you
need it better help once you start
living happier today
visit their website read the
testimonials all right see what's going
on see what's poppin
all right visit betterhelp.com kats
that's better h-e-l-p
joined over 1 million million million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional again
professional this podcast sponsored by
betterhelp
and king of sting listeners and viewers
get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com k-a-t-s
man you want to be a boss imagine the
freedom of being your own boss
running your own business that's what
you want man
and helium 10 wants to tell you how to
embark on a smart career
where you call the shots you work for
yourself
all right best way to work from home be
your own boss is by becoming an
amazon seller amazon isn't just online
superstore it's actually a marketplace
that connects amazon buyers amazon
sellers
anyone can become a seller thanks to
fulfillment by amazon
or fba to helium 10 software
all right helium 10 is an all-in-one
software suite designed to help
promote people like you to launch your
own goddamn business how about that
how about that helium 10 is like a
business in a box
no invention or big idea required helium
10 will find you the right product
to sell right now and handle so many
other aspects of your business
so you can get launched fast plus the
startup costs for launching business on
amazon are much smaller than you'd think
a fraction of other ventures that may
require a ton of money
helium 10 has been used by over 1
million people worldwide
help 10 users collectively account for
roughly 4
billion e-commerce sales per month say
what
work when you want from wherever you
want take advantage of this incredible
offer for helium 10. get 50 off your
first month
of helium 10 platinum account when you
go to helium10.com
kats that's helium h-e-l-i-u-m-1
0.com k-a-t-s don't wait
get 50 off your first month go to
helium10.com
cats oh we got race my case that's right
uh this is a segment where we uh our
judge justin he reads us unique cases
and we
guess the race of the pers of the
perpetrator what up king and the same
crew
judge justin again back with another
race my case let's get right into this
one
i got a guy coming from pennsylvania who
broke into a woman's house and instead
of stealing anything normal like maybe a
tv or jewelry or something like that
this guy made off with seven hundred
dollars
and a hundred and sixty dollars sex doll
now one's willing to spend 160 on a sex
doll i think stevie weeby
should definitely be sliding in those
dms
have you been in uh where's the north
carolina
i knew he was going to bring me up stall
i'm saying white because the sex doll
thing
um why is everyone looking at me
man they're two other people i mean um
yeah so we all were waiting for your ex
yeah i could if it was a probably a good
quality one
yeah um and so yeah 160 a lot for those
six thousand feet that's cheap
like was it depending on there's
different kinds there's yeah for a full
body yeah i feel like it should be like
1500 yeah
flush like a really good quality
flashlight it's over it could be over a
hundred dollars
oh wow so if it's like a whole body
that's a different level so 160 is cheap
yeah so yeah he probably seemed like a
regular blow up was that i want to know
where he stole his teddy rubber
inflatable
what do you think should i say something
else just to be different no guy was
all right we got some white guy yeah
what is it nick
that's an easy one oh i'm sorry is that
mega mine
[Laughter]
yeah dude check out the big brain on
brad can we show the other picture when
he's off the mat
why is his brain so big he looks like
the mars attack guy that goes backwards
all right we got another one from justin
king to see crew back again with another
race my case and this one is pretty
disturbing guys
so a man was charged with his own
mother's death in the
in the year 2000 her body wasn't
discovered until
four and a half years later this dude
kept his mom in a [ __ ] deep freezer
in his house
um police asked him what happened he
said that she died from natural causes
and was scared that he would get framed
for her murder he also said there was
blood splattered on the walls
and that was from when her cat attacked
her years ago
the dude was able to keep this all a
secret by simply just taking the money
out of her
out of the account that they shared and
not telling anybody about
it what a sick [ __ ] race my case boys
yeah yeah what'd you say the cat the cat
there's a cat
oh no that was the name the mom is
probably little
you know to keep her in the freezer it
sounds white but just to make sure
but just to mix it up i'll say latino
yeah latinos love that i'm going asian
he's going white
asian guy i can't tell you that i guess
he's a white guy
of course of course steve yeah they're
all going to be white
or this is going to be an issue you
can't do this segment unless they're all
white
you don't know that this is the first
white one we've had oh wow
oh well because
all right south side chicago all right
gunman shot seven
innocent people yeah he fits the bill he
looks like he's
i mean just not the grace we're all oh
that's a white guy yeah i've mixed it up
no one sees it coming if you go black
black black in a row
no one that third one no one gets right
but yeah we have two
horrible looking white guys that guy uh
that crime i actually gave to justin
that happened in my hometown
uh he was collecting her social security
uh
for four and a half years hustle and
then someone went viral and they
sold bumper stickers that said your
mom's cooler or my mom's cooler than
your mom and it was an arm sticking out
it's dark that's horrible so why didn't
he just
bury him yeah why do you put in the
freak why are you doing so did he
go to prison for murder uh he i think uh
he didn't murder i think it was just
like not disposing of a body correctly i
don't know yeah
there's some kind of charge so how long
do you go away for it for that
that's way more suspicious yeah like why
i'd have to look into it i think he
actually got out of jail recently it was
in 2005. he's
clearly not all there no no he probably
went to jail for social security fraud
yeah yeah
that's what he went to jail for uh but
uh there was probably other charges they
have all these little misdemeanors for
that
why was the blood on the wall he said
that maybe it was the cat i don't know
maybe legit was the cat i don't know yes
white [ __ ]
that's weird yeah that's a horror movie
in the making right there ugly white
people
uh who got that right anybody everybody
steve
steve got it yeah two to one yeah to one
i like this last one okay
what's up king in the same crew judge
justin again i'm back again with another
race my case
i got some funny ones for you guys today
so let's get right into this one
all right first off a woman burned down
a man's house after he called her for a
booty call at 4 00 am and then fell
asleep on her
can you believe that [ __ ] anyway a
failed booty call turning red alert
when a woman from new jersey showed up
to a home of a man who texted her for
sex at 4am
and then passed out on her so instead of
getting some ass
this [ __ ] went to the gas station and
got some gas she bought a lighter
some lighter fluid and literally lit
this man's house on fire
all because he didn't answer the door at
4am after he called her
for some sex breaks my case boys let's
figure this one out this is reminded
this is reminding me a left eye from uh
from tlc down to andre
she burned that motherfucker's house his
mansion yeah
mansion so nine bedroom mansion yeah so
i mean this could be
this could be fiery this could be black
or latino
yeah she's this ethnic woman yeah i'm
gonna go black
from new jersey to those but it could be
like one of those jersey shore
type chicks yeah i'm saying oh this is a
tough one i'm gonna throw a curveball
el salvadorian oh wow i like it wow nice
because that's like the spice well
that's latina though
right yeah that's specific yeah there's
a specific one
i'm gonna go white girl i'll go black
yeah because it's in the new jersey
ah we knew it black girl black girl you
know what that the first
that's why i said i i don't know i know
you know
that's why i went that's why i was like
i know it's like that's definitely
that that's like yeah i did it that's
the facial expression like i i
yeah that looks like don't call me yeah
don't call me and not take care of me
yeah
at four o'clock in the morning crazy
yeah i don't know what they say a woman
scoring right
he'll have no fury all right now we got
some uh cats confessions
oh i love this yeah we already started
with steve's
this is fantastic yeah i think it could
be good like beating that yeah
no they can you finish me off yeah
okay these are puppy dog guys yeah okay
these ones are enough all right so about
17 years ago i was in sixth grade
i was having a sleepover at my buddy's
house
i decided to sneak out do some hood rat
[ __ ] by myself
when i came back i forgot to close the
fence gate
all the way we all woke up the next
morning to their family dog gone
nobody ever found her again i never told
him
what i did and that i knew that it was
my fault the dog ran away
in 17 years and nobody knows it was my
fault
they do now you're hearing this sorry
trevor
gang gang damn he sounds really sad
about it
by the way if your dog
is the only thing keeping your dog there
is a gate
the fence that dog don't like you
correct
cause dogs are dogs always come back you
know what i'm saying they're like
that dog was probably getting abused and
that dog needed to escape
yeah hey trevor you did that dog a favor
yeah yeah yeah you don't feel bad about
that [ __ ] at
yeah is all dinner time [ __ ] yeah
what's going on you know what i mean
there's no way
there's no way that the dog you know
unless the dog got hit by a car
yeah like that that's why cats don't
give a [ __ ] yeah cats or whatever
just dogs yeah yeah dogs or yeah so i
don't he sounds pretty beat up about it
yeah he sounds
still not better than stevie's yeah that
doesn't that doesn't mean
he got a blow job from a man yeah
and he knew it when the man walked in
the room but from the from the
from the jump from and then
i need you on my side on this one 49
70 30 maybe even 75 20. see how you know
90 10.
no no definitely not 90 10 right chin
yeah thank you yo what's up guys
david i got a kinder stinger
so what i've done is i've been seeing a
girl for like
six years or so but
i have an issue with uh
those good old asian rub down locations
uh i wouldn't say i frequent them but
also wouldn't say i don't
what do you think about that have a good
day guys
do you look at me on this one so he's in
a relationship but he's going to rub and
tugs
yeah i mean that's your thing bro
did you consider that cheating it
probably yeah that's definitely cheating
yeah easy ass man over there
i was single at the time by the way in
my defense so i didn't cheat on anyone
that's that's a tough one that's tough
it is cheating though
i mean i'm not telling her i wonder if
he talked to his yeah i wonder if he
talked to his girl
i mean she'd much probably prefer him
getting jacked off at the
at the masseuse than him like in a
full-blown
[ __ ] [ __ ] some friends or
something so that's different
it's still it's still not great but yeah
it's better than the ultimate still
cheating
yeah this one's probably my favorite yo
what up guys
gang gang sting singing
just giving you guys a call that you
know back in the fifth grade
another fifth grade me and my boy we
found a little pornography
and it was called raw orgasm
we were in the fifth grade and it was
full penetration
we got took that thing to class we
ripped out a page and just passed it
around
and uh i dared this kid
to tell me and oh my boy chris and he
got suspended for three days
oh keep it up big dogs
we need to go to instagram find that guy
yeah and let him know yo dude you need
to hear this
[Laughter]
that would be awesome if we do the maury
povich right yeah we should you know
yeah
and you call them and you go you then
you call this guy and then you get the
other guy to come on you got to set that
up
and trevor who lost his dog yeah man
trevor this is what happened
dude so he snitched on his buddy his
buddy got suspended for it
yeah and he was the one that brought
that that's traumatizing as a kid
yeah that guy by the way it sounds like
he's like a little older
because he wouldn't come because first
of all i know he's older by the way
because in his in the fifth grade they
didn't have phones
yeah like imagine that's like you have
to pass porn around
yeah that's like it's so like like a
penthouse you were the man
yeah but but his friends probably
traumatized because i had a similar
issue there was a guy it was the pee
bandit
there's a pete there's a guy peeing on
the walls at the school right yeah
they call them the p band and they even
did over the intercom like whoever's
peeing on the walls at the school
you will be found and prosecuted
whoever's doing that's like god damn i
got a real pm prom here
and then my buddy brandon was taking a
piss and he we were in fourth grade but
he'd pull his pants all the way down
and i thought it was funny was being i
grabbed and shook him he started peeing
all over the wall
and while i was doing that the teacher
walked in they're like there's the piss
bandit
they prosecuted the rent they prosecuted
me for it
i got spent for a week to call my
parents and [ __ ] but but
did okay here's what i want to know this
is interesting though
did someone after that piss on the wall
anymore nope someone was smart
that's wow or or i was the best
[Laughter]
my dad my dad was so mad oh i'm sure oh
my god he was mad
he was probably mad that you were like
touching a boy while he was busy what
the [ __ ] were you doing
yeah i just spent for a week in fourth
grade traumatizing oh yeah
yeah probably messed them up because
they had to like [ __ ] me take care of
you
for a week yeah man well that friend
owes him like something i was like andy
dufresne from shawshank redemption i
didn't do it
exactly uh so stevie and brendan have
both confessed something you got
anything eric
um no not really
in kindergarten uh
they they pulled their dicks out at
lunch and they were like showing people
i
i don't know we were young like big
dicks uh no i
i don't there was no reference point at
that sure
yeah you you didn't put like a quarter
next to it and you know
to get together i'm literally getting a
pit in my stomach right now
i went and told on them i i ratted him a
piece of [ __ ] that was like the last
time i've ever snitched on anything
i got something another story but
i remember meeting somebody at camp all
right there was this girl like
really young okay and so then it was
like
she and her family invited me to their
place
you know like and it was like i forgot
so long ago i don't remember where it
was but it was kind of rural
you know but i remember they had like a
really cool joystick
atari it was it wasn't a target but it
was like whatever kind of thing it was i
remember it was like a plane
thing you know and i stole it
i stole it no because it was like but i
was you think you're so you invite
somebody to your place
[ __ ] you know what i mean prize
possession i always thought later too
was like because they were white
too yeah and i bet you they thought
afterwards like this is why
this is why we told you not to have that
griffin kiddo you know and it was just
like i always remember that i was like
that's one of my
bad moments of like being a little thief
and i wasn't like a normal like a klepto
or anything like that right but it was
just something like oh i really want
this and you just got you know i took it
well i remember as
most of my friends were predominantly
african-american i grew up
around all black people and my friend
brandon invited me to his birthday party
and uh we there's like monkey bars we're
all in the monkey bars
and his mom and like grandma were behind
me and
they they made some comments on me being
white previously as his friend
like i was his only white friend and
they would like make fun of me for being
white which is whatever when i was young
and then he was on the monkey bars and
he was so good at it
and i said in front of the family i said
damn you're like a monkey
remember i'm like seven you don't know i
was like oh you're like a monk you're so
good you're like a monkey
bro she grabbed me by the [ __ ] air
and tore me a new one man well that
wasn't racist call me racist
oh dude here's the thing though i was
never don't call them monkey bars i was
never
yeah i was never allowed to hang out
with them again she never allowed me
over again but that was her own baggage
yeah i was like well i get it you know
that's just that i remember being like
no monkey bars
monkey yeah they're like nah [ __ ] you
racist pieces no
no
yeah so i was at my friend's house
where i had discovered masturbating
before all my other friends i think
maybe
why are we not surprised yeah i mean
maybe fourth and
fifth grade maybe jesus dude so we're in
his um
uh i guess a game room or record you
know foosba or the show
and so i taught him we're both naked
um side by side side by side
and he and i said hey uh do you know
you're not a master
beat off he goes no and i go i can show
you and so i just remember we had a
jug of vaseline oh and so i just
remember um
both of us going like that and
him like not being because it was he was
getting stage fright
yeah he's yeah because you're so he's
next to him thank you that can't get
hard
yeah and not so that was my confession
that's a solid one too stevie you've
trumped us all man yeah steve i didn't
know steve was like a you know
jack off coach yeah jack off the
tutorial he comes in with a whistle
grab that tub of vaseline timmy yeah
but you know powerpoint presentation
must have felt great though because the
you know yeah with the vaseline i also
want to point out
in steve's reenactment his dick was this
big
i just wanna
yeah but i mean steve this big
so what are you saying man hold up i
want to know what you're getting at at
least he wasn't like
at least he wasn't like nick and
snitched on you to his mom
no this is i was being a friend you
would've gotta expect
anything to confess you know 40 years
like i don't know you're young i mean
it's like
how that that is just as innocent as oh
yeah sure
you know what yeah you're just people
but like her the parent could have came
in and i'm like
you've done so much you know what i mean
it's just your point of view because
they've dealt with so much
and they're probably just like just that
just triggered them and they're like are
you saying in my situation no yeah in
your situation
and they you know traumatizing i i
guarantee you afterwards when they
thought of that they're like oh he's a
kid oh i don't think so no i don't think
so
she's like she's like where's your hood
at like
only my dad wears that and then next
halloween you were a ghost and they
[ __ ] flipped
like get the [ __ ] out of here
i
i'm trying to think back i don't i can't
really think of anything good chin never
has
any stories i have it's like it's like
he's a spy
terrible mine is just bad like i was a
bad person that kind of story but not
like
nothing like crazy that was
life-changing like what kind of what
kind of bad person
how did you discover masturbation
oh my god
i think 10 12. i i remember the first uh
picture i jacked off too was the the it
was like was it
cash money remember the mercedes her
name was mercedes
she was the only female uh rapper on the
roster
and she she was over like a low rider
and somebody did it to her but
yeah that's why i'm an ass man i
remember
humping a pillow yeah and then like i
ejaculated and i didn't know what the
[ __ ] that was you know i thought i was
like something was wrong with me you
know what i mean i was like oh my god
what is that
what is that
when you're a kid and you know how like
the bubbles fly out then you put your
penis near the hole the jacuzzi
oh it felt great starts thinking you're
taking the jets
no well not though just not going on
vacation with steve
you think i would do something like that
first thing yes you got a hot tub
wait a minute is that not the realm of
possibility that steve's still not
putting his dick in the jacuzzi hole
hey man i don't want to carry my black
ass to hawaii you guys get a hot tub
this picture was a favorite of mine in
middle school
wow wow you were young
but i mean you're my age you mean by
middle you mean by
17. i'm six years younger than you yeah
i guess that's fair this is before she
shaved her head man
oh god i didn't know the titties were
like that yeah oh yeah she was
back in the shoes too oh my god
all right all right if you think of
anything let us know yeah
all right chin never shares [ __ ]
because he's like because he's like a
he's a plant you know like those russian
subterfuge like you know what i mean
like like black widow yeah
i mean like it's very strange it's like
a russian spy and they put it they say
go on a podcast
is that a cultural thing because koreans
are a bit you know like reserved
yeah no i think the my stores are just
they're like
like gang kind of stuff not like us try
it
what kind of game what kind of gang vans
are we talking about here like it like
what's the reason why he can't get a
real job is what we're finding out
that's a legit point
like lord honda we did all that but one
of my
closest family members i'm not gonna say
you know who that person is no we don't
need names it's a gang member
and so was my best friend at the time
[Music]
asian gangs
okay so we would just get into really
bad violence and i remember one day
someone tried to fight me so then we
ended i said let's meet over here
and we brought a bunch of weapons well
they didn't show up so if they would
have showed up
that would have been my my life right
there for sure you guys were going to
kill him
i think we were going to be we're going
to like shoot first but if they shot us
first
it was going to be crazy dude you see i
told you these are not good stories
you think you know a [ __ ] right
she's like here's the thing man this
guy's talking [ __ ] you're a good
no boxing match [ __ ] yeah why is it
asian gang members like pool halls
was it like a pool hall dude we were
there all the time too yeah what was
that about asian
gambling gambler too so i don't know
it's a skill and you gamble
asians are really good at pool too they
are black widow
yeah uh what's her name jeanette lee or
something sad sorry about her she has
cancer
i guess the best pool player in the
world is uh from vietnam or some [ __ ]
wow philippines or something like that
yeah grogan was talking about him
jeannette lee she yeah she was about us
i remember that she was
they had her on tv all the time yeah she
was on these right
yeah yeah so how do you make money doing
pool is there other competitions
tournaments yeah there's tournaments
just like anything
any kind of competitive thing they find
a way to monetize it
my girlfriend is like really good at
pool like she'll go to a bar
and like put quarters on the table and
people like oh who's this and she just
kills them but she won't
she won't play in front of me she won't
play with me because she's worried like
i'll be so bad
it'll turn her off that makes sense man
one time i was in montana
and it was like i had this like like it
was super you felt the race tension
okay we just done a show i was the only
person of color in the whole building
you know and they were playing pool
against and i could tell the local
pool shark guys at the table
you know and he like
i i don't know how i i did some lucky
shot
or or it was like a crazy shot no he was
like gonna try to win the game and the
black ball
went in so then they lost came up so
then it was our table now
you know and man i thought he was i
really thought he wanted to like murder
me
he was passed yeah cause now we have to
wait you know you know what i mean bro
we're in
uh tacoma over the weekend you know i
travel with david lucas
yeah yeah uh i have chappelle who's
black and
then justin who's black so my whole show
is black except for me
and they were literally the only black
guys we saw the entire weekend we'd go
somewhere
and me and dave were getting lunch and i
got he said weird bro
didn't it weird how people stare at you
because you're the only black guy
waiting tacoma yeah and he's like [ __ ]
but also david lucas
you know yeah but he's a whole hundred
percent dude and he's got
weird 400 pounds yeah he sticks out but
he just freaks out
but so how about he he uh it's on the
new vlog but he
some some you know he's a roaster so
some girl starts shouting
in the middle of the set then she walks
on stage he's like [ __ ] what are you
doing and i was like oh my gosh she can
get lit up
and she goes i'm from dublin you think i
don't give a [ __ ] where you're from you
think because you're
foreign you can get on stage and then he
just lights her ass up
she goes sits down and i watch i i sit
in the back where no way you can see me
i watch the show to see how everybody's
doing
and so i'm sitting back there and the
guy and his wife stands up and this guy
looks like a proud boy shaped head and
everything
oh [ __ ] and he's throwing a [ __ ] fit
in the back
and he goes i came here i came here for
one reason
one reason only i can't for one reason
only brandon chobb
you got all these [ __ ] up there bro
oh hell no
so then uh david goes get off stage he
goes right that's my time
and everyone's clapping and he goes get
off the stage
hard and bomb from the back nobody heard
it because the crowd was so loud but i
heard it
i was like oh my god security was like
get the [ __ ]
he's out yeah he's out but then
is this when did the this is this the
guy that rushed the green room
uh no different guy damn
i wish it was that guy listen to shops
oh my god well
how was the rest of the show they were
great
[Laughter]
it also made good content for david
because he lit this [ __ ] lady
up man so i that's why the husband was
pissed oh yeah all right this guy's got
a debate club
what's up eric stevie and brendan this
is your boy raymond aka robert fattenson
cause i just can't get rid of that
quarantine 15 can i
got a debate club for you we saw jeff
bezos going to space a couple weeks ago
and i got to thinking
how much would you pay to go to space
zero because a million dollars seems
like it would be about right
but if you get too cheap like 25k 50k
yeah
spend airlines you gotta risk it to get
that biscuit but at what cost
so let me know what you think gang gang
buzz buzz i appreciate you all
lions are zero i would pay zero dollars
to go to space
bars well mars different they're not
going to mars bro and technically you
to any like nasa like legit they're like
bro they're not in space
they're reaching like the upper layer of
earth before it gets to outer space yeah
they're not getting to space
oh no so like elon and all them they're
not getting the space tank well
if they're eventually they you know i
mean you got to be trained like they're
going to have the space center
station you should look at that stuff
like the space station is pretty good
that's fascinating
that's yeah it's growing and other stuff
so it's pretty fascinating if it was
like total recall like
you could go to do it to with three tips
oh yeah
yeah but we're not there yet we're so
far away from that and did you see that
one astronaut who was like
up in space for a while he has a twin
and how it deteriorated his body yes
like don't believe the movies we're not
close to that
at all we don't have i don't think we're
supposed to either we don't know so my
thing with jeff bezos
they said it cost them i don't know like
seven billion dollars to get to space
bro we got problems here yeah take that
seven billion put into the earth dog
[ __ ] space let's figure out the things
here then move on
yeah it's like that yeah or how about
this we don't
know where that count no here's my thing
we don't need to know about it like not
everything has to be like
like what are you flossing like this for
it's like he should think like that like
i don't care what he does with his money
it's not up to him to spend his money on
you know
whatever right so my thing is like are
you gonna you know basically waste your
money because you have it
you don't gotta tell us about it yeah
just do it he can just do it yeah
like like five years now he'll be like
yeah you know i went to space uh and
like damn you did yeah
check out this check out this you know
what i mean
you know you don't like these rich
people do your rich people [ __ ] don't
rub it in our faces exactly
you're rubbing it on basically actually
keep it on the dollar you know what i
mean he's going to be the first troll
you can relate to that you know that
yeah
exactly especially because the first
thing we go to is
oh man there's poor there's homeless you
all that we start thinking about all
this stuff
that ain't their responsibility fair
point you know what i mean so it's like
but at the same time it's like don't rub
that [ __ ] in your face when we got
all these things that are going on in
the world right now
must be nice must be exactly to go to
space must be nice man
that's the owner of orange county
chopsticks
what up brendan what up eric what up
stevie weeby this is dee
coming out of sonoma california north
bay 707
uh no i'm not in jail i'm just over at
the lowe's here yeah
uh brendan i saw a theory the other day
in front of my house yelling at one of
my neighbors and then i just realized it
was one of my coked up uncles but
i got a debate club for you uh them
schwarzenegger movies
and you can't be saying it with a hard r
around here oh whoa terminator 2
or predator i gotta go terminator 2.
that's my favorite i thought i was the
young john connor riding my dirt bike in
the streets as a kid
i just wasn't smart enough to get into
the atm
so let me know what you think debate
club
gang gang blood blood baltimore i gotta
go against him man i'm going commander
i'm going for
predator predator is my favorite i like
commando like total recall
just because
cree he was in predator yeah bill duke
yeah predator was good
better it was like it was a great movie
because it started a generation of
movies
yeah it also gave every young boy did
they still ruin yeah
we all wondered who was edward furlong
right edward yeah as the
silver guy that was a pretty good one
but dude come on man look at that
support dude have you seen terminator uh
terminator arnold schwarzenegger's son
who he had the kid who he had
with the maid the mexican yeah he's jack
yeah he got all the genetics
yeah i would say predator i'm a stupid
and he's a hard worker
and that's the key there
yeah he got he got the genetics of his
daddy because then the other one is just
like look at him dude
who's who's who that's his son on the
left jeez
louise he looks like his dad genetics he
has the one son who's just like you know
kind of a soy boy
you know he's like i can never look like
that man
even if i lift it there's no way you
never do steroids stevie
no i mean just lifting i couldn't like
my body type could not do that
i think you could nah yeah physique work
is like a lot of that i mean you know
right brandon yeah it takes so much to
like yeah he could do it
to get that you can do it you got you
got the you got the thing for it i want
to
i i i tell myself all the time like like
for just once in my life can i just be
in shape why not dog
i want to do it it's just hard to hit
the gym i need to just challenge myself
and just do it
cause sometimes when i game i do this
thing i call my exercise cam
so like if i don't get 10 kills in a
match you get 10 kills
uh but i just i don't always but the
point is for exercise i'll say like if i
don't get it then i'll do
goals i have goals and i'll do like uh
squats up to this point so i'll always
do 10 squats and then i'll be like
however many kills i don't get i'll do
more squats so then i i i do like this
whole workout while i'm uh
playing video games you know so it's
like if not now when
yeah i know man have you guys seen this
clip a lot of people have but it's
arnold talking about the feeling the
pump gives him
it's pumping's like coming
it's like gold back in the day in venice
yeah i don't like this stevie's all does
he get massages
that's the greatest
is the pump let's say you drain your
biceps
blood is rushing into your muscles and
that's what we call the pump
your muscles get a really tight feeling
like your skin is going to explode any
minute you know it's really tight it's
like somebody blowing air into
into your muscle it just blows up and it
feels different
it feels fantastic
what's up with the music it feels
fantastic come on do it
it's a satisfying to me as a [ __ ] is
you know as
having sex with a woman
how much i am in heaven i'm like getting
the feeling of coming in the gym i'm
getting the feeling of coming at home
i'm getting the feeling of coming
backstage when i pump up when i pose out
in front of 5 000 people
i get the same feeling so i'm coming day
and night i mean that's terrific
yes in the maid yeah i mean
do back then
wow crushing it that's it genetics
love it man uh what do we got when am i
in north carolina
uh chin looking up right now is it
august 19th
21. august 19 21 i'm in north carolina
then end of the month i'm at la jolla
comedy store
it's a thursday friday saturday no
sunday show sunday we have a fight
companion
we also have a fight companion this
saturday with myself
bradley martin um josh thompson tj
dillashaw for ufc 265.
are you gonna do the pacquiao whatever
what that what oh that's not we haven't
done boxing but we could yeah should do
that yeah earl smith
i'm still trying to do it um okay i got
i'm gonna be
in at the mgn mgm grand in vegas from
the 9th to the 14th at brad garrett's
club
and i also have at on the 19th just one
night at the brea improv
thursday yeah one night in brea on the
19th
so please check that out then i'll also
be in escondido
at grand comedy club on the 20th the
next night but
that brea one come on out breath people
la area
uh if you go to my if you're on my
instagram i got the link there
i got to put it on my shitty website
yeah yeah stevie scissor bros
youtube.com slash scissor bros
what what about stevie weeby's show
stevie youtube.com
steveweeby thank you love it mr theo
see you guys brennan and theo fighter
and weight i gotta go in and go hard in
the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
vernon ate the queso and the quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
king and the sting beast
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you